boa tarde minha grande prazer estar aqui
apresentando para vocês internet
no primeiro terry e pra mim é um grande
reconhecimento do trabalho que tenho
feito e vou compartilhar com vocês aqui
a história de uma criança
a história de uma criança muito curiosa
dizer que desmontava todos os brinquedos
que ela tinha era um brinquedo que tinha
um propósito
ela descobriu como as coisas funcionam é
descobrir por que as coisas eram daquela
forma é entender como as coisas
acontecem
esse problema tem que ser resolvido com
os pais dessa criança era pra alguém
leve porque felizmente o desmontado e eu
fui crescendo muito em altura pessoal eu
sou a idade até que eu cheguei no meu
colegial ao público uma vez no colegial
eu já gostava muito de trabalhar com
computadores eu era toquinho dos nerds
da escola tão e automaticamente em dia
também
ele é meu amigo e por essa curiosidade
ele queria entender como as coisas
funcionam eu decidi junto de alguns
amigos mas cinco anos
nós queríamos fazer alguma coisa
diferente nós temos a curiosidade de
entender como a nossa escola funcionava
nós queremos juntar àquele espaço ainda
que fosse um espaço pequeno ainda fosse
o nosso mundo
dessa forma novos vão falir anos na
escola e criamos três projetos nos
organizamos a sala de informática da
escola com o programa de monitoria para
permitir que os alunos pudessem passar a
utilizar sal
nós criamos um sistema de controle da
biblioteca começamos a catalogar todos
os livros da biblioteca para poder abrir
essa biblioteca os anúncios e nós
queremos bater veicular uma espécie de
leilão como nós temos aqui é gee de
mantida por nós ou seja feita pelos
alunos para os alunos é o conteúdo
criado por nós fizemos a licitação do
projeto básico
isso pra mim foi uma coisa incrível
porque foi a primeira vez na minha vida
que eu pensei que eu disse ao meu
conhecimento e aqui e essa minha
curiosidade para transformar o mundo
melhor não fosse a uma escola
uma popular da china lutas mas agora
neto popular que não sabia que não é
daí eu saí da escola obviamente
continuar crescendo
definitivamente não mais em outubro e
cheguei até a faculdade
e aí o confuso com o qual é o dinheiro
porque assim com muitos de nós talvez
chega à faculdade com uma expectativa
muito grande e eu fazendo isso mas com a
notícia a carta branca da direção da
faculdade não tinha mais que isso e
olhar o menor estava em 20
eu já que é legal porque eu ia pessoas
que conheço também é que tinha
conhecimento e também de aplicar aquilo
e aquilo nunca acontecia não ia pra
frente e eu tenho perdido e procurando
somente assim ainda ficou assim até hoje
uma faculdade mas ela tinha uma coisa
que é interessante para a minha rotina
eu trabalhava com o cfm empresa
trabalhava na avenida paulista no centro
de são paulo e eu estudava na zona sul
de são paulo no centro universitário
a distância total menos uns 20
quilômetros a de diversos e para chegar
ou sair às 17 horas a chegada da menina
na minha falar eu tinha que pegar o
metrô
outro metrô ou entrem caminhar e depois
não tinha que caminhar mais um pouco
mais humanos mas outro lado surge em
casa
isso geralmente funcionava muito bem
esse é um funcionário
no dia eu tava lá dentro do trem fazendo
esse projeto e o trem parou entre as
estações e aí comecei a olhar ao redor e
falar poxa é porque o caminho é treinar
funcionando
são paulo tem 2800 linhas de de
transporte mas linha do trailer novo 15
mil ônibus a caminho da vitória e que as
pessoas também tinham estado em que
também havia uma possibilidade de saber
se transforma em publicar essa
informação está disponível no site da
companhia não tinha essa informação na
palma da minha mão que as pessoas ao meu
redor
todas tinham celulares smartphones e
tomei uma decisão eu contei a pergunta
que eu queria esconder
eu cheguei na minha faculdade conseguir
chegar hoje eu tinha esse problema
daí o coxa é preciso é isso que eu
preciso fazer e assim eu comecei a
empresa tcs menino mas o mesmo nome do
nosso grupo de vontade do colégio
gonçalves é é a idéia da tecnologia que
é o conhecimento que eu tenho que é
aquilo que influencia em termos técnicos
não gosto de ver a tecnologia
funcionando para o a benfeitoria social
para melhorar a condição das pessoas
para colocar as pessoas em um controle e
aí começou o projeto
a primeira coisa que nós criamos como
sei é se foi o ônibus ao vivo que um
aplicativo de celular simples que mostra
pra vocês
você não pode mais o ex mostram instalar
o carrinho também ao fim de fato essa é
a grande vantagem disso não é
simplesmente pela tecnologia celular ou
alguma coisa do dia a grande vantagem é
dar um tony o deslocamento das pessoas
com as pessoas é justamente aquelas que
precisam mais desse torneio justamente
as pessoas que são mais carentes desde
nosso próximo tem celular tem um iphone
mas não sabe a que horas ela tem que
sair de casa se elas também têm essas
dúvidas não sabem que horas vão chegar
se ela não chegava até se transporta
funcionou dessa história é o nosso bem
no comecinho veio pra mim falou o
seguinte olha grêmio nem com essa
aplicativo que vocês fizeram porque
agora eu consegui saber onde o ônibus
fará antes de eu sair de casa com 15
pontos e também pra mim foi incrível foi
sensacional porque eu comecei a perceber
que o problema estava resolvendo mais um
problema com geléia ou mel trazendo
conforto das pessoas está melhorando a
vida delas na cidade ou a joc orson
autoridade minha talvez eu pudesse levar
isso para frente talvez pudesse evoluir
esse conceito é simplesmente uma
plataforma com isso mais pra frente
pensar porque não tem uma plataforma
inteira não de toda a vontade da cidade
pode se conectar não de todos que
dependem desses locais da cidade podem
se integrar podem se interessar em casa
através da tecnologia porque dessa forma
então só pessoa sol o cidadão eu tô o
cidadão está ajudando também a empresa
de ônibus
aqueles em curso deve província fez
melhor que está ajudando o prefeito da
cidade a construir a cidade que as
pessoas querem tudo encerramento a ele
esse foi um conceito que nós criamos
contra as células
essa plataforma graças a isso hoje em
dia nós já temos aí nós já temos aí mais
600 mil downloads do nosso aplicativo
cada dia e descobrir de novo nessa
talent eu não sei tudo pra fazer com
isso
dois meses atrás eu escutei que a gente
ia ficar algum modo transporte e
melhorar o quadro de intendentes
automatizar a preferência de uma empresa
da qual nós estamos falando essa foto na
seleção tótens na cidade de são paulo
vários pontos de ônibus da cidade de são
paulo mostrando levando a informação de
quando o ônibus na chegada pessoa com as
linhas passam naquele ponto
a gente consegue fazer isso ter o
aplicativo totem instalado de sms por
meio de vídeo que isso coloca a pessoa
em poder do controle
graças a isso o projeto brasil e um de
recursos afi a última volta eu não vejo
são paulo e tive o prazer de começar
entendem melhor
uma vez lá ó problema está resolvido
porque houve três curioso nessa história
uns organista no seu dinheiro tá e aí eu
comecei a entender que o problema que
nós vamos resolver não tentamos não há
problemas começaram quando um chamado
por organizações
hoje no brasil mas 186 milhões de
pessoas já moram em centros menos que a
estimativa do banco mundial estima que
até 2050 70 por cento da população
mundial morrem em regiões urbanas ou
seja o agente garante essas pessoas
saúde educação alimentação direito de
cidadania
tudo isso passa pela unidade a partir do
momento da cidade começam a crescer
e aí eu entender isso não levou mais
profunda
eu nem um pouco mais profissional de
ambos assim mas nunca vejo nenhuma
verdade seja dita essas fotos são
mágicas sobre modelos de transporte ou
moscou as pessoas se deslocam à cidade o
uso do espaço público pois é eu acho as
imagens muito bonitinhos mas eu acho que
ela simplesmente porque elas são bonitas
elas não servem pra nada assim para
deixar o seu carro desde então eu quero
compartilhar com vocês uma outra lesão
um pouco mais séria fazer comparações
é um dos maiores defensores da cidade
crescendo
eu tenho um ônibus a um canto direito
nunca esquerda é 35 pessoas em nada
nesse ônibus e levou a 15 metros no
avião
são 15 metros de comprimento a
associação nacional dos transportes
públicos tinham que a ocupação média de
um veículo hoje no brasil é junto às
pessoas focadas para as mesmas 35
pessoas em veículos novos em uma quadra
e meia o fato é que o carro com um
espaço gente pergunta que fica para
todos vocês é informa o trânsito
nós vamos além
uma outra ótica 63 mundial afetou mais
de 50 pessoas
quando cheguei mas convenhamos 50
pessoas ainda podem ser a passar o
corredor tranquilo nem cartesiano velho
nós temos aí mais de 12 vezes mais de
energia de pontos de responsáveis e além
de sete vezes mais poluição eu o promovi
mostrar que consegue ser pior ainda mas
é um atleta
- é melhor - metal não adiante questões
o que a gente tenha praticado o que a
gente quer fazer o nosso futuro nas
cidades com que a gente resolve
na minha opinião e na visão do gramado
nós precisamos desconstruir a cidade com
os ossos em golpes velho assim
complicado no rs
nós vamos construir conceitos precisamos
construir idéias que nós temos o
deslocamento super à vontade e souber de
política através de tecnologias como
esta apresentando através de interação
social é que a gente começa a andar ao
fórum da cidade para que ela não seja
joga o carro porque ela precisa ser
algumas pessoas ela precisa ser formada
pelas pessoas é uma aglomeração de
pessoas
quem além do carro a uma pessoa então a
cidade precisa ser feita por pessoas e
para as pessoas e não mais para o
automóvel
a gente tem que abrir a mente pra
começar a discutir esses problemas para
começar a questionar isso e desmontar
esses conselhos para que a gente comece
a consumir a partir daí as cidades devem
ficar em um exemplo disso eu posso
compartilhar com você
aqui é mais um pau a gente tem um
projeto e outro sem tanta falta a
prefeitura que deixa a principal avenida
da cidade à avenida paulista e
independente da questão política é eu
estive lá eu fui em um visitante nessa
dessa menina de quem aos trancos ou
gente assim que você poderia criar uma
vida que geralmente é absurdamente
movimentada que você tem medo de ser
atropelado e você tem a tranquilidade de
poder caminhar e olharem a agora
confirmar a obra ontem a favela eu vou
atravessar a rua e você simplesmente
esquecer o barulho da cidade aquela
coisa toda
no meio de são paulo a sensação de poder
se apropriar do espaço ea gente precisa
de mais casas atingidas e demais
iniciativas
eu pergunto pra vocês como vocês teve um
agenda tem carro preso no trânsito ou em
seus próprios olhos as suas próprias
pernas
no entanto na rua interagindo com as
pessoas têm uma real internar de se
deslocar para poder chegar aonde você
espera
será que as nossas cidades
pra isso será que nossas pessoas estão
preparadas para isso
é um grande momento de ir pro fundo
brasil pra nós fazemos essa refeição a
mobilidade pessoal ela que nos permite
isso conectar para compartilhar 10
eu garanto a vocês se não fosse pela
possibilidade de deslocamento de um
binário link você está livre
quanto mais nos permitisse às pessoas
morro se locomover mais mas permite que
ela se cometem quanto mais elas se
conectam e essa é a magia das casas é a
conexão das pessoas quanto mais
importantes que as pessoas cometem mais
nós criamos chances para mudar o mundo
então convido todos vocês
passei a debaterem a discutir em assim
se é organizar e enquanto sociedade
enquanto lage anos enquanto pessoas que
estamos vendo pela internet que a gente
crie mobilidade que a gente quer ver
nossa cidade dessa forma através do
mundo
dez dessas conexões que só são possíveis
através da mobilidade a gente possa
começar a mudar o mundo em um lugar
melhor
muito obrigado pessoal